welcome to this video please Stonewall
double-oh-seven from where bahrain the
rain okay let's see maybe I should've
played the stone wall ki cream pawn
opening an early g3 this b5 set up a sub
provided good recipe against that just
prevent before a prevent c42 is try to
play that anyway hmm I'm not sure maybe
you can be formed
our black has some quite a solid center
here white can go see for but then I
capture and play c5 yeah let's not spend
too much time I probably won't
completely refute that anyway and I
think that is that probably many ways to
obtain a satisfactory position like this
this is certainly a playable position
for black yet one nicely developed here
and he's got a potential a weak poor
nonton be three yeah not potentially it
is a week pawn it's also a passport but
it's mostly a week porn I hope to to to
really get something going against it so
um Kubek look um and I would like to get
a look to be aid of course but not with
this Bishop
Bishop f6 is something that I can also
consider but i'm not sure if I want to
have a position like Bishop f6 text
Knight takes Knight c5 this is why I'm
trying to first improve them at the
pieces rupee aid first would be a tween
b7 something like that
interesting okay i thought i had thought
about this anyway
hmm yeah probably i'm not i'm not sure
but it feels like something has gone
wrong here
hmm
I mean I'm not I'm not in trouble or
anything but I'm certainly not not
better in this position maybe maybe I
never was but I liked I liked it a
thought let'em that the beat porn was
more weakness than a strength try to win
a tempo here rookie 87 I have hookah c8
okay so need to probably get out of this
yeah I don't mind I don't mind this
exchange I want I want my king near the
center this is the the only thing going
for me really at the mode my king is
quicker in the center and if he takes
rook takes less Kingda 6 coming with
chances to win the beep all yeah this
looks nice actually forward and for
black oh sorry let's let's go here oh I
could take the night here
something to consider
if i take the night bishop retreats
I'm not sure this some this seemed fine
to me try to attack the pawn Knight e5
to see six senses the the idea and this
night also is harassing the sponsor he
cannot easily move the king yes now if
five
or your form you for takes takes d3 it's
not leading to much okay
ok 6 I wanted to prevent that
97 95 okay
so g5 does Luke f7
playing on 495 f3 here with them
attacking ideas
time warning it's really that and the
soul I thought this was a bit dangerous
but he's got h4 right check check check
yeah what a silly game I don't really
understand what what happened here yeah
every I have no idea where it went wrong
I was just I just had the better aunt
game but just played it but I'm not
quite sure how Jamie where exactly I
made the mistake check check check check
yeah I can also resign on eros on time
anyway black raise I cluster the
position of course I'd really are really
curious I mean I'm just better in the
same game but when did it rain wrong I'm
playing with a king on d6 so it's it's
clear that black is better but what
exactly did I do wrong here maybe this
wasn't so great I don't know yeah yeah
fo of course I can play you for but this
is this is just just a draw and I mean
draw is not what I wanted here so and
now we had Roque one
yeah it's it's probably just the draw
mean maybe I need to do that this is
this kind of stuff but it feels very
weird like black should be better here
really i mean the pro here I playing
with the king he he's not playing with
his King the computer wants to go d 4
but I didn't didn't consider that at all
takes and kinky five yeah maybe I didn't
didn't consider that
yeah this keeps keep the edge problem
now I played all the right moves here
until there simply wasn't Jack no trick
at all what can you do I just played
this and game very badly maybe it was
just a draw but I need to play this D
form of problem King c5 also is just
good i mean this was also clear i could
take with the king but yeah maybe i
should have done that actually this is
much easier to play because he doesn't
have a night it's also a good structure
it's it's it's it's the same let's say
something like this it's just a good
structure this part is weak and I can
try to to do something like that a tacit
and at the end probably win it all so
this means maybe this was even better
but this was I need to play this default
this default push interesting it game
yeah I hope you enjoy it i miss played
it but it was interesting thanks for
watching